a bunch more bombshells breaking in the
FBI texting scandal Plus president Trump
wants a military parade and Democrats
are filibustering a government for a
government shutdown again i'm ben
shapiro there's the bench bureau show
yes many things are happening the
Democrats are claiming that the end of
the Republic is upon us why because
President Trump wants a parade you know
a shiny things and toys and tanks and
such it's gonna be awesome Democrats are
very upset about it however they say
it's the end of the Republic however if
we're gonna talk about the end of the
Republic and the destruction of
governmental norms I have a few notes on
that first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at upside comm so when
you book your business travel there is
only one good way to do it the way to
book your business trip is it upside
calm we use it here at the Daily wire
whenever I book I booked through upside
calm and when you do you will get a
better business travel experience that
you deserve and a free pair of Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones first
here's why your life you'll love upside
comm so first of all upside has
concierge service I mean we're talking
24/7 to make sure your flight hotel
rental car
although off without a hitch they're
available on demand by chat phone and
email whenever you need them only upside
monitors your business trip around the
clock they proactively keep you posted
on everything from the weather in the
city you're going to to changing your
flight home so you can adjust your
meeting schedule you don't get this
level of service with any other travel
website and right now you can get a free
pair of Bose Soundlink wireless
headphones all you have to do is go to
up side comm slash bend that's upside
comm slash Ben and when you book a trip
you get your Bose Soundlink wireless
headphones the headphones are available
while supplies last yeah it has to be
your first upside purchase and a $600
minimum purchase required which is
basically a round-trip ticket see the
site for complete details upside calm
and slash Ben that's upside calm slash
Ben again when you use that slash pen
you know that they let them know that
we've sent you and also you get the pair
of Bose Soundlink wireless headphones so
pretty good sweetener just for using a
site you should already be using for
travel anyway alrighty so the Nemec rats
are very very upset Chuck Schumer
sounding off Senate Minority Leader he
says that our government is becoming
degraded Republicans are silent about
Trump they won't speak up about Trump
and it's degrading our Republican
Republic is is just falling apart at the
seams here is Chuck Schumer for partisan
reasons the president and his allies in
Congress are systematically trying to
weaken America's faith in the rule of
law and to a large extent
sadly the leaders of the Republican
Party have been silent we
desperately need more of our Republican
friends to stand up and speak out
particularly the Republican leadership
because their silence is rapidly
becoming complicity in the denigration
of our republic so as you know from this
show one of the things I hate most in
politics is the sincere voice where
everybody goes down real low like they
mean it and that's we get from Chuck
Schumer it's a pretty good indicator the
person's lying to you when they go to
sincere voice if your spouse ever was
talking to you
they said honey I really took out the
garbage you can be guaranteed that the
garbage never was taken out it never
happened so these politicians are lying
to you but the Democrats are saying that
the the Republicans are destroying
governmental norms what was the big norm
that was destroyed yesterday by
President Trump the big norm that was
destroyed yesterday by President Trump
did the Trump says he wants a military
parade so according to cnn.com his ask
the military for a parade and the
Pentagon is reviewing potential date so
the White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she said in a
statement trumpet ask the Defense
Department to explore the idea
she says President Trump is incredibly
supportive of America's great
servicemembers who risk their lives
every day to keep our country safe his
ask the Department of Defense to explore
a celebration at which all Americans can
show their appreciation and the
Washington Post reported last month that
Trump wanted a military parade
apparently he visited France and he
really liked the bastille day military
parade he said last September in a
conversation with with the president of
friends McCrone that when he came back
from France he wanted a military parade
on the 4th of July in Washington there
are a lot of people who are looking at
this and saying well what the why do we
need a military parade me number one it
cost a lot of money number two the idea
of tanks rolling down American civilian
streets when we haven't just won a war
we're not actually celebrating anything
or not on Memorial Day or not on
Veterans Day is kind of weird like you
just randomly do a military parade in
the middle of Washington DC so the Trump
can stand there and look over the troops
that he commands seems kind of not an
American thing like the last military
parade we had in the United States was
1991 that was after the Gulf War after
we won the Gulf War and George HW Bush
had a military parades who could
celebrate the returning servicemembers
we had a couple back in the 1960s we had
one under JFK there's one under FDR
which is really creepy because there's
like actually a giant head of F do
things I have a bust of FDR that was in
the parade it's all real weird well is
it something that I love the idea I
don't love
idea of this I love the idea of honoring
the military that's why we have two days
honoring both the following members of
the military and the members who
observed right we have Veterans Day we
have Memorial Day and we should all take
time out and we should pay homage to the
military that's something that we should
do on a regular basis but the idea that
Trump wants his military parade so he
can stand there and look over and I find
kind of weird again appreciation for the
military is one thing Trump wanting to
imitate France because look at all the
pretty Jets seems to me a little bit
weird as well is it however the end of
the world is it something where you look
at it and go this is destroying the
fabric of the Republic no no is it is it
a waste of time and money I kind of
think so is it something where you know
we actually need to do it is it
something in Trump is doing for his own
personal gratification kinda but is it
the the end of the Republicans we don't
know but doesn't matter rather the
Democrats naturally are going crazy
because they'll go crazy over over
anything
representative Jackie Speier from
California she says that Donald Trump is
clearly like Napoleon what's your
reaction to that idea I was stunned by
it to be quite honest I mean we have a
Napoleon in the making here and I
believe that we have so many issues
around the world in terms of preparing
for Wars that are ongoing and wars that
may be you know in the offing because of
what's happening in North Korea that I
would say that it's really a waste of
money
and I think everyone should be offended
by his need to always be showing he's
he's he's truly Napoleon like okay come
on come on just silly talk okay and then
Jeff Flake gets up yesterday on the
floor of the Senate we discussed the
president Trump had said the Democrats
or he joked the Democrats were
participating in treason when they
didn't clap for him in the middle of the
State of the Union which as I said was a
dumb remark he was obviously joking Jeff
Flake who is not running for reelection
in the Senate in Arizona because he
would probably lose he has now made it
his mission to go on the floor of the
Senate every chance he gets and say
things about Trump's that he can
presumably primary him in 2020 here is
the senator from Arizona I wish I could
stand here today and say that my words
of last October have been proven wrong
that I had been unfair to inveigh
against the daily Sundering of our
country that I had been mistaken about
the personal
tax that I had exaggerated the threats
against principles freedoms and
institutions the flagrant disregard for
truth and decency I have seen the
president's most ardent defenders used a
now weary argument that the president's
comments were meant as a joke just
sarcasm only tongue-in-cheek but treason
is not a punchline mr. president
okay so again is this over-the-top yes
is it is it listen shouldn't Trump have
said any of that stuff no but the idea
that Trump is degrading the Republic
beyond belief okay the election of
Donald Trump versus Hillary Clinton was
the worst choice ever okay remember all
the way that forget about what Trump has
done since that I like all his policies
the election between Donald Trump a guy
who is manifestly manifestly character
free in many ways and Hillary Clinton
the most corrupt politician in modern
American history that was not a good
election okay we're gonna talk about
stuff that degrades the Republic however
stuff that has real impact on the
Republic
we can't start with Trump saying stuff
about military parades or suggesting the
Democrats are treasonous for not
clapping for him as I mentioned
yesterday Democrats have said for years
that you were treasonous if you did not
sufficiently support Barack Obama's
agenda they said it over and over and
over they suggested the tea party where
actual terrorists for not supporting
Barack Obama's big spending agenda all
of that was stupid
none of it made any sense but nobody
said at the time this is the death of
the Republic they say it because it's
Trump and of course Democrats are going
over-the-top out all this stuff because
this this is where they think they're
going to win they think they're going to
win by just crying not normal over and
over and over Joe Biden did this as well
Joe Biden comes out and he says that
Trump is a joke doing everything that
Vladimir Putin ever wanted this is the
first president to make a full-throated
unvarnished attack on the entirety of
the FBI what do you think they're
thinking in Moscow this is doing
everything that Putin ever wanted I just
I I just marvel at some of the things he
says and does like what two days ago
anybody didn't stand up and clap for him
was on American and then maybe even
treasonous
they say it was tongue-in-cheek
Democrats can't take a joke well I may
say he's a joke he's Joe Biden obviously
wants to run in 2020 as well remember
Joe Biden is the guy who got up in the
middle of this
twelve election cycle and said Mitt
Romney wanted to put y'all back in
Chains but if that's not the definition
of treason you know if that wouldn't be
him calling Romney a traitor I'm not
sure what would be they wants to enslave
his fellow Americans this sense it's an
astonishing claim so Democrats are
claiming that Trump is destroying the
Republic but who is really destroying
the Republic who is really making the
the institutions of the Republic less
than credible well it really is not
Trump so much it really was the Obama
administration I have a lot to say on
this particular subject there's some
breaking news I want to bring to you but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at 1-800 flowers so you
know Valentine's Day is coming up and
you know you're lazy you know that
you're not gonna do anything up until
the day of Valentine's Day and then
you're gonna rush over to the local
grocery store and you're gonna pick up a
box of chocolates and bring it home to
your wife and she's gonna look at you
like this is all you did well that's why
you should instead be going over to
1-800 flowers calm right now they always
have my back in tight situations as I
mentioned when I went to the Superbowl
and my wife was not super fond of it
that meant it was a good time for 1-800
flowers to calm right now you can get 18
enchanted roses for only $29.99 18
enchanted roses for just $29.99 it's an
amazing offer from 1-800 flowers calm
it's a gorgeous bouquet featuring
radiant pink and red roses the perfect
Valentine's surprise she is guaranteed
to love and she will never guess how
good the deal was and that you didn't
spend that much money on her so if
you're just a cheap sob you weren't
gonna spend that much money on her
then you can at least get her something
really nice anyway and this one at 1-800
flowers calm is for they are the rose
authority to order 18-inch ants and
roses for just $29.99 go to 1-800
flowers com click the radio icon and use
promo code Shapiro's remember tease that
promo code Shapiro's so you get the
special deal Valentine's Day is almost
here you need to order today 1-800
flowers calm promo code Shapiro again
you get 18 enchanted roses for just
$29.99 1-800 flowers calm and use promo
code
Shapiro to get that done okay so there
is a bunch of breaking news that shows
who is really endangering the
institutions of the Republic and the
answer is it was the Obama
administration I mean there there are a
lot of problems that I've had with the
Trump administration but we talk about
destroying the institutions of the
American Republic there was so much
going on in the last election cycle that
was troublesome and before that for the
last eight years before that I mean I
wrote a full book on all of the
corruption inside the the
Obama administration called the People
vs Barack Obama it's worth reading but
in the last couple of weeks there has
been a letter from Lindsey Graham and
Charles Grassley a referral to the
Department of Justice and the referral
basically says a few things it says
according to Gabriel mailer is a lawyer
he says first that the October 2016 FISA
warrant application seeking surveillance
of Carter page disclosed did disclose
that the Steele dossier was compiled at
the direction of a political client it
did not disclose that it was compiled in
the direction of the DNC at the time of
that warrant application the FBI thought
Steele had not previously disclosed
dossier information to anyone but the
FBI and has quiet it turns out that he
instead disclosed to the media and so in
the original application they used both
the Steele dossier and a media report
based on a leak from Christopher steel
tube media the FBI believed that that
was Steele's first media disclosure but
it turns out that it was not and so they
fired him and they did not include that
in the in the warrant right subsequent
to April 2017 they did not include in
warrant renewal applications the new
information that still had previously
lied to the FBI about media disclosures
prior to October 2016
therefore all states quote instead the
post April 2017 applications still
relied primarily on Steele's credibility
prior to the October media incident so
we're still figuring out exactly what
was going on with the Carter page 5sy
application well we're still figuring
out exactly what happen with the Carter
page FISA application there's some new
information that is pretty damning as
far as how the FISA application process
works the most honest take here I think
is that the FISA application process is
deeply flawed since to the initiation of
the FISA courts which is back in I think
2000 to 2003 since the initiation of the
FISA courts there been a grand total
something like 21 FISA applications that
have been turned down by the FISA Court
so basically the FBI brings information
to the FISA Court and they rubber stamp
wiretap that's a serious problem because
in this particular case the information
that the wiretap of Carter page was
based on was really sketched not only
was it really sketchy it may have come
directly from Hillary Clinton sorry we
already know the steel dossier this this
dossier that was compiled at the behest
of fusion GPS which was being paid by
the DNC
that steel dossier was used as the basis
for the FISA warrant or as the primary
basis for the FISA warrants against
Carter page the
the DNC was paying for it but we're now
finding out that that wasn't the only
way that Hillary Clinton was funneling
bad information to the FBI or may have
been doing so according to a report from
Mark Hemingway over at the Weekly
Standard the FBI is now investigating a
second Trump dossier this one is
complete with information allegedly
compiled by a Clinton crony named Cody
sharor Natasha bertrand of the atlantic
says she's seen the memo and then it
covers quote a range of allegations
concerning the president's personal
behavior and financial transactions
according to Bertrand Obama's State
Department special envoy to Libya a guy
named Jonathan Winer passed information
from Shearer who is a Hillary buddy on
to British spy Christopher Steele was
busily compiling opposition research on
Trump on behalf of the DNC and Hillary
Clinton via fusion GPS so here's how the
chain of information went there's a
Hillary Cronin named Cody Shearer he was
working with Sidney Blumenthal sandy
Blumenthal is Hillary's hatchet man and
one of the sleaziest Liars in the
history of American politics Sidney
Blumenthal and Cody Shearer were working
to compile information that may or may
not have been false to hand over to
Christopher Steele they didn't just hand
it over directly to Christopher Steele
however instead they sent it to Jonathan
Winer Jonathan Winer was working at the
State Department right he was working
for John Kerry at the State Department
he was a Hillary staffer who moved over
to - John Kerry and so the State
Department then funneled that
information not to the FBI but to the -
Christopher Steele who included it in
the fusion GPS dossier which eventually
was forwarded to the FBI so it looks
like the State Department being
militarized on behalf of Hillary Clinton
to funnel information to Christopher
Steele who would then send it to the FBI
which would then look to target the
Trump campaign right that's what this
chain of information looks like as
really really dirty stuff a Hemingway
rightly sums up if the Guardian report
is accurate the FBI had better have a
very good answer for why it's looking at
information compiled by the likes of
Cody Shearer and if steal otherwise
incorporated shares information into
zone dossier it raises even more serious
questions about what the FBI knew about
the reliability and provenance of steals
information which all makes the page
Pfizer requests look shoddy or and
shoddy or if the FBI knew that steals
information came from Hillary's buddy
and was funneled through the State
Department that's damning stuff it looks
like the militarization of the State
Department and then perhaps of the FBI
on behalf of the Hillary Clinton
campaign now that would not be a supreme
shock if the FBI was biased on behalf of
the Hillary Clinton campaign late on
Tuesday evening Fox News released a new
shocking report on
texts between FBI agents and lovers and
lovers Peter struck and Lisa Paige both
of them you'll recall were fired from
the Mueller investigation for bias
against President Trump so according to
Fox News page this is Lisa Paige in
relation to Carter texted to her to love
her Peter struck on September 2nd 2016
with the news that FBI director James
Comey wanted them to prepare an update
on ongoing investigations because quote
POTUS wants to know everything we're
doing which sounds like Obama wanted to
be updated on a routine basis on the
Hillary Clinton investigation a Fox News
says that this is about the Hillary
investigation not about Trump Russia
collusion now it makes this weird is
that Obama had said back in April of
2016 that he did not interfere in FBI
investigations that he didn't want to
know what's going on in FBI
investigations is clip 16 here is Obama
saying that he would never get involved
in investigations directly as president
just a button is up I guarantee it you I
guarantee that there is no political
influence in any investigation conducted
by the Justice Department or the FBI not
just in this case but in any case and
she will all stop period and she will be
treated no different heed full stop
nobody gets treated differently when it
comes to the Justice Department because
nobody is above the law
even if she ends up as the Democratic
how many time do I have to say Chris
guarantee guaranteed guaranteed but here
he is saying I want updates now listen
he's the President of the United States
he can have updates on any case that he
wants obviously Trump has the same power
but the idea that Obama said that he was
not gonna get involved in any of these
investigations and then suddenly Obama
was going on national TV and saying that
he didn't know Hillary had a secret
email server and he found out about it
on the news even though he was obviously
emailing with her at her private email
address the fact that the FBI and the
DOJ deliberately overlooked that the
fact that the FBI and the DOJ were
coordinating on the Hillary email
campaign the fact that they were texting
I mean those texts show that they wanted
to go easy on Hillary because they
thought that she might be the next
president of the United States all of
this makes the FBI and the DOJ look
incredibly dirty makes it all look
really dirty Molly Hemingway has a piece
over at the federalists talking about
that Grassley Lindsey Graham memo that
has now been sent over to the DOJ and
again according to that letter it says
it appears the FBI relied on admittedly
uncorroborated information funded by an
obtained for secretary Clinton's
presidential campaign in order to
conduct surveillance of Minnesota
the opposing presidential candidate it
did so based on mr. Steele's personal
credibility and presumably having faith
in his process of obtaining the
information but there's substantial
evidence suggesting that mr. Steele
materially misled the FBI about a key
aspect of his dossier efforts one which
bears on his credibility so all of this
is is pretty damning all of it suggests
that there's some dirtiness happening
here and all of it needs to be reviewed
I mean we here's what I really need at
this point if we want to actually figure
out what's happening there first we need
the FISA okay Trump needs to declassify
the FISA warrant application on Carter
page because all we've been hearing from
the Democrats is that Republicans are
leaving out key components all we've
heard from Republicans is that the FISA
application shows that there was some
sort of collusion going on between the
FBI and the Hillary Clinton campaign
we're not going to know the answer to
any of that until that actual FISA
application is released now what this
seems to me is that there's two possible
theories one is that the Trump campaign
was being targeted by the FBI on behalf
of Hillary Clinton the other is that the
FISA applications that are that are
sought by the FBI are really shoddy on a
regular basis right if it's the latter
then we have a very deep systemic
problem with the process if it's the
former then we have a very deep systemic
problem with the quote-unquote deep
State and the FBI I always tend to
attribute you know this sort of stuff to
to stupidity and incompetence rather
than malice but I can't take malice off
the table because I just don't know at
this point I Trey Gaudi was already on
TV last night
essentially hinting that it was the
Hillary Clinton campaign sending
information to the State Department for
Anansi Steele which is forward onto the
FBI and a pipeline of information here
is the representative from South
Carolina so weeks before the election
somebody in the Obama State Department
was feeding information from a foreign
source - Christopher Steele when you
hear who the source of one of the
sources of that information is you're
going to think oh my gosh I've heard
that name somewhere before where could
it possibly have been and find source
the domestic source and I'm trying to
think how Secretary Clinton to find him
I think she said he was an old friend
who emailed her from time to time I'd be
really warm if you're warm
yeah so it is Sidney Blumenthal
apparently according to trey Gowdy all
of which
deeply troubling to anyone of decent
mind meanwhile I mean if you want to
know again who's destroying institutions
in the United States it doesn't help
when Trump attacks institutions wrongly
I've attacked him when I thought that he
was doing so but it was the Obama
administration that was compromising the
integrity of these institutions and it
was these institutions who apparently
you compromising their own integrity
with either bad Intel they were
funneling to the FISA Court or FISA
courts who aren't willing to do the work
necessary to suss out whether an
American citizen ought to have a warrant
put on him despite lack of evidence all
of which is deeply troubling again the
Democrats are willing to believe pretty
much anything and I Adam Schiff the
Democrat he essentially said yesterday
that he was caught on tape being print
by radio hosts who claimed they had
naked pictures of Trump that just shows
how how willing the Democrats are to
believe anything about President Trump
okay and SaLuSa met with Trump in New
York at some point after the 2013 Miss
Universe yes absolutely and she got
compromising monteri also entrap after
their short relations okay the nature of
the compromise
well there were a pictures of naked drop
okay and so Putin was made aware of the
compromising material okay so good stuff
there obviously Adam Schiff getting
pranked by a couple of Russians who are
calling him up and saying that he is
that he is apparently going to be given
pictures of naked Trump whatever gets
whatever you know get your rocks off
apparently so in a second we are going
to discuss the latest episode in
government shutdown because I guess
we're gonna have to do this every couple
of weeks here but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at blue
apron so blue apron is the leading meal
delivery kit service in the United
States and a lot of people may know what
they do but they don't know how good the
recipes are okay we're talking about
seared steaks and thyme pan sauce with
mashed potatoes green beans and crispy
shallots in under 45 minutes short rib
burgers with a hoppy cheddar sauce on a
pretzel bun right this gourmet stuff
you're making it in your own kitchen
it's the number-one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
okay again they're making incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone a
lot of people in the office use blue
apron they have a two-person meal plan
with
that serve a couple of people you choose
from eight new recipes per week with the
choice to receive either two or three
recipes in any given week a family meal
plan meals that serve four people again
you choose from four new recipes per
week with the choice to receive either
two three or four recipes any week they
even have a wine plan six bottles of
wine from renowned wine makers delivered
on a monthly basis it's convenient
there's a lot of variety there's a lot
of flexibility they offer 12 new recipes
each week depending on which program you
have chosen and they are high-quality
they send only the best ingredients and
the blue apron is treating my listeners
right now 230 bucks off our first order
if you visit blue apron comm slash up
hero again that's blue apron comment
slash up here you get 30 bucks off your
first order and I mean these things
sounds amazing these are amazing strip
steaks and potatoes and spicy maple
collard greens and come on this is this
is good stuff and you're gonna be making
it in the convenience and privacy of
your own home with your family I love
cooking with my daughter at home you'll
love cooking with your own children as
well blue apron calm / appearing at $30
off your first order when you visit blue
apron calm / Shapiro okay so with all of
that said about the the compromising
information regarding the Carter page
files warrant we need to see the actual
FISA application and if we don't see the
actual FISA application is just going to
turn into everybody accusing everybody
else of treason all the time and that is
not going to be beneficial for the
Republic in any way shape or form
meanwhile in in another development that
is certainly not going to help the tenor
of political conversation in the country
we're now on the verge of another
government shutdown so this is exactly
the same as the last government shutdown
as I predicted right here on this
program no deal has been made on daca
nor will any deal be made on daca
remember we have until I believe next
week for them to reach some sort of
continuing resolution though or I guess
tomorrow for them to come up with any
continuing resolution it continued to
fund the government Republicans of
course are fine with continuing
resolutions funding the government I've
spoken with a sitting United States
Senator Republican who's livid over this
he says why is it the Republicans can
never just go through regular order
regular order as the process whereby
each department of the government is
funded individually you don't have
omnibus projects that our budget
packages that are all wrapped up
together instead you have each provision
being debated openly and freely on the
floor of the Senate that has not
happened instead there's a continuing
resolution to continue funding the
government at current levels essentially
as the Sen
put it to me this is a this is a
pilotless plane it's a ghost plane it's
essentially the the American budget is
now a ghost plane nobody has control
over it it just keeps flying because
nobody is willing to actually sit down
and hammer out a budget if they do
hammer out a budget it only grows in
size and scope right now the debate over
the continuing resolution is whether or
not the Democrats will allow the
government can to continue to be funded
if no daca deal is cut or no promise of
a daca deal is made now the Trump
administration has already offered a
deal that deal is extraordinarily
generous that deal includes the
legalization of 1.8 million illegal
immigrants and a pathway to citizenship
for 1.8 million illegal immigrants it
also includes the possibility of the
importation of another 4 million legal
immigrants into the United States right
through chain migration which would come
to an end but only gradually over the
course of the next 20 years right all of
that the Democrats have decided is if no
merit instead they just want a full-on
daca right now they want a full amnesty
they don't want to spend any money on
the border wall they don't want to spend
any money on border security it's really
absurd and so Trump is responding how
you'd expect from first mine by saying
listen you want to shut this down over
immigration and fine shut it down over
immigration again you did it like two
weeks ago and it was a complete fail on
your part we don't change it let's have
a shutdown will do a shutdown and it's
worth it for our country I'd love to see
a shutdown if we don't get this stuff
taken care of
so we have to strengthen our borders not
by a little bit but by a lot we are so
far behind the time and by the way the
world is laughing at us because they
can't believe these policies they don't
have it I could name 15 of them right
now no other country in the world has
what we have and we're gonna get it
stopped and if we have to shut it down
because the Democrats don't want safety
and unrelated but still related they
don't want to take care of our military
then shut it down okay no with another
shutdown right now Trump continuing to
say shut it down shut it down shut it
down is not good politics he should be
blaming Democrats for the shutdown
saying listen I want the budget you want
the budget everybody wants the budget
they won't give it to us because of daca
that'd be the smarter way to do this
board he's saying is essentially correct
that if the Democrats decide to shut
this thing down over immigration again I
don't understand how this is any
different than it's been since we did
this like two weeks ago when we did this
two and a half weeks ago and at the time
Chuck Schumer argued
that we should shut down the government
over daca it failed it's the shutdown
started Friday it ended Monday and he
got essentially nothing for his trouble
other than some bad poll numbers so
Trump is exactly right here to hold the
Democrats feed to the fire and John
Kelly who is very very hawkish on
immigration Trump's chief of staff and
spoke to the media yesterday he said
listen we've offered a lot more than
other people have offered he makes a
comment in here the Democrats are
seizing on trying to claim his racist of
course because that's the way this works
the president sent over what amounts to
be two and a half times that number to
1.8 million the difference between 690
and 1.8 million were the people that
some would say were too afraid to sign
up others would say were too lazy to get
off there but they didn't sign up so the
president shockingly said okay 1.8
million and then probably the biggest
shock was in a path to citizenship
that's beyond what anyone could have
imagined whether you're on the right or
the left so people on the Left went
crazy of us how could John Kelly suggest
that some people were too lazy to sign
up for daca okay maybe some of them were
lazy maybe some of them were not that's
not the main point here in fact is that
a lot of people didn't sign up for daca
specifically because they were concerned
that if they signed up and then Trump
revoked daca they would now be on the
government's radar so I don't think
that's quite fair of the White House
chief of staff that said this is not a
winning issue for Democrats doesn't
matter
they are beholden to their radical
Democratic base and that's the one thing
that Trump always can count on here is
that no matter what crazy stuff Trump
does the Democrats will do something
even crazier so Nancy Pelosi has decided
to get up in filibuster she may still be
filibustering this daca it's hid they're
calling it a daca buster cuz not
technically a filibuster in the house
she says she's gonna get up there and
she's gonna talk and talk and talk and
talk as of this speaking she is still
talking I believe she's nine hours in at
this point and she's still jabbering on
about why it is that we can't pass a
budget why we can't fund the government
because we need to instead cut a deal
legalizing all illegal immigrants not
just in exchange for border security but
just plainly so here's Nancy Pelosi
starting to jabber about this today the
Republican moral cowardice must end
members of Congress are trustees of the
people and of our nation why are we here
if not to protect the patriotic young
people who are determined to contribute
and to strengthen America so I'm going
to go on as long as my leadership minute
allows I not to speak to the the Bible
in Luke 10 25 37 the parable of the Good
Samaritan there's nothing I like better
than when Nancy Pelosi an abortion
fanatic quotes the Bible it's one of my
favorite things she should definitely
quote the parts of the Bible talking
about God knowing you before you were
born she should definitely quote the
parts of the Bible talking about the
value of the life is you should
definitely talk about the parts of the
Bible talking about same-sex marriage
she talked about all the parts of the
Bible they're a little less convenient
for her than these broad-based notions
that we have to take in every immigrants
on earth which of course is not true and
it's not necessarily mandated by the
Bible the Bible is full of walls right
the Bible is full of injunctions about
who can marry whom and which people are
allowed to intermingle without which
other people you know the idea that that
the Bible is an open borders document is
relatively belied by the text of the
Bible itself so no no and by the way
that's not that's not a suggestion that
the Bible itself is against
intermarriage with regard to race for
example that's a suggestion that the
Bible is very much in favor of
boundaries that establish the sanctity
of certain of certain practices and the
sanctity of certain populations I mean
obviously the Bible is is all about the
sanctity of the Jewish people least in
the Old Testament and it says that there
are people to be kept separate in
certain ways so the Bible is not all
about the idea of full-on everybody gets
to come in and every person is of the
same mindset that's that's just
silliness all of this is to say that
Nancy Pelosi is now willing to shut down
the government again over daca the
Democrats are willing to shut down the
government again over daca this is a big
mistake by them it is a huge mistake by
them and and in one second I'm gonna
explain why it's a big mistake by them
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wire calm right now and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wire calm
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get the rest of the
Michael Mol's show live you get the rest
of the Andrew Klavan show live and in
doing so you will also be able to be
part of our mailbag which is coming up
in just a couple of days for our annual
subscription for $99 a year you can get
this the very finest in all beverage
vessels leftist ears hot or cold tumbler
and when you get that tumbler you will
just experience the glory of
conservative feeling and thought flowing
through your veins
down your gullet into your stomach it's
incredible so get that annual
subscription now or go later listen to
the podcast over at SoundCloud iTunes
please subscribe over at YouTube and and
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so one of the reasons that it's so
stupid for Democrats to Clinton they
want to basically shut down the
government over daca is because the
Democrats are constantly wanting to cut
the military budget and Trump sort of
made reference to that a little bit
earlier when he said that the Democrats
are willing to let the military go
unfunded in order to protect illegal
immigrants Democrats are constantly
looking to cut the military at the same
time they're looking to expand the
budget for social services and various
other spending initiatives in general
James Madison general transmeta
Secretary of Defense he came out and he
says listen the worst thing that can
happen right now is for us not to end
sequestration sequestration was a budget
cap that was put in place the Democrats
insisted that half of the budget cap
come from cuts to military spending
because Democrats are anti military and
here is what mattis had to say about
that in Assam only yesterday we need you
to pass a budget now if we are to
sustain our military's primacy we need
budget predictability Congress must take
action now to ensure our military's
lethality is sufficient to defend our
way of life to preserve the promise of
prosperity and to pass on the freedoms
we enjoy to the next generation and I
ask that you not let disagreements on
domestic policy continue to hold our
nation's defense hostage now this is
always the one place where Democrats are
willing to cut the budget they're never
willing to cut the budget anywhere else
as an example Democrats are now calling
for a new Child and Family Leave plan
one that is more generous supposedly
than the one that's being pushed by
Ivanka Trump and Marco Rubio so senator
Rubio and Ivanka Trump are trying to
come up with a paid family and medical
leave program that would essentially
allow you to take money out of your
Social Security to cover your paid
family and medical leave and the
Democrats people are left very upset
about this they say instead that we
should just have the government borrow
from the Chinese essentially to pay for
it elizabeth Bruning writes a piece over
in washington post suggesting that is
our obligation all of our obligation to
pay for other people to take paid family
and medical leave she writes early in
the fifth century the theologian st.
Augustine of Hippo noted something about
families in society that in his era was
simply conventional wisdom after the
city or political community comes the
world following the Convention that
treats the household city and world as
three successive levels of human society
but the ancients families were the first
and smallest of societies units of
cooperation their order within which
people learn to get along with others
together families form political
communities cities
Augustine put it and together these
political communities made up the world
which was a Society of communities peace
and order in each contributed to the
peace and order of the next and the
society had an interest in fostering
functional families and families had an
interest in funk in forming functional
societies okay all of that is true but
what she's about to suggest Ness is
suggest next is that it is the job of
the government to ensure that we pay you
to stay home with your baby for the
first six weeks is what sends it all
made and how strange it is to have
completely dismissed the idea in modern
thought our world is one of individuals
making a series of contracts and
agreements with one another in hopes of
getting the most one can out of the
world lives of the others have not our
none of our business and Arthur none of
theirs know is that nowhere is this
clearer than in conservative
policymaking where family policy is
absurdly individualized and she makes
the contention essentially that we
should turn the family into a government
concern again now this is one of the
dangers I'm reading a book on on ancient
thought and modern political thought as
well and one of the dangers of a lot of
ancient thought is there's the
suggestion implicit that a lot of
ancient thought that if the idea of the
human being is that you are virtuous by
exercise of the Faculty of reason if the
idea is that your virtue is tied up in
being a good citizen of a community as
Plato and Aristotle both suggest then
why isn't it the job of the community to
function in making you a good citizen
why isn't the job of the community to
basically make you a cog in the wheel
and Plato's Republic he talked to length
about the idea of fostering the sort of
utopian vision for a society in which
families are governed by the state in
which children are removed from parents
and educated in a certain way in which
the wisest of the children are put in
particular sorts of schools right all of
this is dangerous stuff once you say
that the community is responsible for
the family as opposed to the family
being responsible for itself and then
building a community then you end up in
some real trouble the basis of the
liberal public order is the idea that
the family as an atomized group of
people who have care for one another
take care of one another and then they
together with other families form a
community not that the community is
designed to form families and that if
you try talked down to have the
community form families all you end up
with is the community dictating to
families what should and should not be
true because the same government that
can provide you paid family leave is the
same government that can tell you that
you need to educate your child in a
particular viewpoint about the world
this is a serious danger it's a serious
danger
it's the difference between some
enlightenment thought and some of the
pre-modern thought right some of the
ancient thought and even some of the
high that evil thought with regard to
the value of community and family and
the balance between the two essentially
after the after the high middle ages and
after the Renaissance there is a feeling
that's beginning to grow because of the
the high levels of warfare that
centralized state power was a problem
and that the best thing that you could
do is devolve authority back down to the
lowest level which meant in essence the
individual and the family and that
authority sprang from the individual in
the family this is the idea of John
Locke right that there's a social
contract that is made by people who
originally existed in a state of nature
that state of nature by the way does not
mean that there was no government and no
state it just means a state of nature in
which there are very few rules right
there were Oregon self organized
communities but there was no monopoly of
the use of state force is the idea of
the state of nature when the idea in
Locke as as well as in other
philosophers like Machiavelli actually
even talks a little bit about this the
idea in in some of these ancient some of
these sort of first modern philosophers
and the ones that most led to the
American Founding right the idea there
is that family predates society and so
the authority that society has comes
from the family not that the Society's
job is to create the family out of whole
cloth because otherwise what you're
gonna do is you're gonna have some
families using the tools of society on
behalf of themselves and the expense of
other families but this is a little too
complex for for Elizabeth Britax take
she goes all the way back to Augustine
and some of the actions who suggest that
the state's job is toppled the family by
the way now that is unclear from
Augustine anyway right Augustine's
correct when he says that when you look
at the three levels of society you're
looking at family and then community and
then society at large that is true right
of course that's true but Augustine was
also the same guy who proposed the
complete separation of the City of God
in the city of man the idea being
there's a spiritual world and there's
also a physical world
Augustine's words were used to justify
virtually every regime ranging from
Republic's to dictatorships right but
any case Elizabeth brooding over at the
Washington Post she writes considered
the paid parental leave plan teased and
president from State of the Union
address which is now gained traction
with Rubio and truant and Ivanka Trump
the plan described as a budget neutral
approach to parental leave by advocates
would allow parents to draw from their
social security benefits early to fund
their parental leave then
to delay the collection of retirement
benefits by something yet to be
calculated period of time participation
would be strictly voluntary
I don't see the problem with this
proposal by the way we should increase
the age of Social Security benefits
anyway it's ridiculous that it is
currently where it is the fact is we
cannot pay for Social Security it's been
in the red since 2010 paying out more
money than it has been taking in anyway
this this author continues it's a highly
individualized way of dealing with the
facts of family life which by their
nature are communal issues sorry the
facts of family life are not by nature
communal issues they're not by nature
communal issues the facts of family life
are by nature private issues and
communities are formed by those families
again we have to figure out how the
communities are formed suggesting that
community predates family is
historically inane it's not true right
families create communities there's not
and just look at the look at the Western
settlers in the United States there's a
series of families who came out west and
they would settle down with other
families and then they would create a
community it wasn't a community that
pre-existed the family that doesn't mean
it wasn't a bunch of individuals who
went out created a society and then
families moved in that's not the way
that this typically works but she says
babies and children need caregivers
mothers and fathers need full time and
money to give care elderly grandparents
and great-grandparents need
companionship and assistance and
typically speaking historically speaking
that was not a duty of society that was
a duty of the family right babies and
children were given care by members of
the family right a husband and wife
decided how they were going to care for
children is how it works in my family my
wife and I decided exactly how the kids
were gonna get taken care of the
grandparents chip in a lot and we help
pay for a nanny and I'm home a lot and
my wife is home my mothers and fathers
need time and money to give care okay
then they should go out and they
shouldn't make money before having
children ideally right it's their
responsibility to do so elderly
grandparents and great grandparents need
companionship and assistant this one is
particularly interesting historically
speaking it was the children who took
care of the parents one of the reasons
that parents had lots of kids is the
idea that when I get old then my kids
are going to take care of me right one
that was always the idea that you hit 80
and now you need to move in with with
your kids say moving with their kids is
what your kids were there for and then
society decided the government was gonna
take care of the elderly folks and the
elderly folks stopped having as many
kids and so the Social Security
pyramid scheme turned upside down and
now it's bankrupt but in any about
brooding rites at the Washington Post
babies and children learn
groans alts work and produce in the
elderly help and rest there's a place
for every stage of the lifecycle in the
Grand order of things and a just state
what ideally defer to that natural
rhythm right
by removing itself from the rhythm I
mean when the state interferes in the
rhythm by offering incentives or by
perverting those incentives the
standards of doing a great disservice
but she says instead conservatives plan
would penalize the elderly for their
decision to have raised families all in
the interest of making parental leave a
self-contained option no burden to
anyone but the parents themselves it
shouldn't be a burden to anyone but the
parent themselves I know this is
actually an argument incent conservative
circles so there are some people like
rust out hat reihan Salam over a
national review they argue that it is
the government's job to help foster
families that it's the government's job
to help ensure that parents can stay
home more or that parents can can have
more money that is why they believe in
the child tax credit as I've said I'm
not a believer in the child tax credit I
don't believe the parents are
essentially having children in or to get
tax credits I think that's that's a miss
Reid of why most people have kids and
beyond that you know society obviously
has an interest in the in the bearing
and rearing of the next generation the
easiest way to incentivize that is to
incentivize communities to come together
and form their own societies as I've
said many times I've said it in
virtually every speech I've made for the
past several years the order of
preference if you need help should go
family and then community and then the
state it should not be the reverse it
should not be state and then community
and then family if you need help but the
idea here is that Republicans are doing
something deeply wrong in suggesting me
primacy a family not only as the element
of political conversation but also as
the source of help for members of the
family right instead the this says the
proposal would penalize bigger families
more than smaller ones couples with more
children to face working further into
old age before receiving retirement
benefits well yes because it would be
their choice to have those children
moreover it would mean likely that lower
wage workers would end up putting off
retirement longer than wealthier workers
with ample company benefits well yes
it's better to be rich than poor in the
United States as everywhere else in
human history if you're not particularly
well-to-do and you want a family in
other words you'll need to be prepared
to pay for it in your old age your
family your choice your problem yes
except that if you're in my religious
community then we help you out
informally because that's something else
that we need to build up the idea that
government is there to fill all gaps and
that you are not there to actually help
out
members of your own communities another
falsehood promulgated by the left the
idea that the only source of help in
times of trouble is the government is
absolutely untrue but the piece
concludes quote it is actually in the
best interest of society that people
have children it would be in society's
best interest for them to be provided
with the time it means to nurture those
children one of the things that's so
fascinating about this argument by the
way is that the same people arguing for
paid parental leave are the same people
who argue that same-sex marriage is a
grand and great idea same-sex marriage
has no bearing on childbearing and
rearing right the whole reason the
government used to prefer traditional
marriage to same-sex marriage was
because of benefits in terms of child's
childbearing and rearing so it's kind of
ironic to watch the left completely
abandoned in that position even at his
embraces the position that we should
have the government pay for paid family
and parental leave kind of fascinating
but again if you want Liberty you're
going to have to accept it there's some
responsibility that goes along with it
and if you want a family that is free of
government interference you're going to
have to understand that the government
that gives with one hand also takes with
the other okay in just a second let's do
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so let's jump in let's do
some things that I like so over at
Amazon Prime it is now available 13
hours the Michael Bay film about
Benghazi
this thing has 50% on Rotten Tomatoes
that's because critics are garbage
ok this film is very very very good it
is a very good film ok I walked in
expecting it not to be such a great film
because number one it's obviously a very
depressing subject you have four
Americans killed at the hands of
terrorists in Benghazi the film is not
political it does not cover the cover-up
by the Obama administration it does not
cover the fact that none that the the
Hillary State Department refused
additional security requests that goes
very light on the behavior of the Obama
administration in the middle of this
crisis it really treads lightly on that
it's an almost a political film but the
critics hated it anyway because anybody
who mentions Benghazi must be cast into
the outer darkness you're not allowed to
mention the fact that Hillary and the
Obama administration blew it like if I
had made the 13 hours movie would have
opened with Hillary cackling over the
demise of Muammar Qaddafi saying we Came
we saw he died and then it would be
Hillary talking about how grand and
great Libya was and then fast-forward to
what's happening in Benghazi that's not
what this movie does this movie is
really a political doesn't matter the
critics slammed in anyway because anyone
who questions the greatness of Hillary
Clinton must obviously be
operating in bad faith the movie is I
think nearly as good as Black Hawk Down
it's a very very good military military
thriller it's very effective and it's
very moving
here's a little bit of the preview for
13 hours everybody this is Jack Silva
yeah who trained seals in Coronado so he
knows the drill
welcome to club bag
[Music]
we're sisters
still return let's go man
[Music]
the US ambassador at risk the Ambassador
is in his safe haven you're not the
first responders with a last resort you
will wait
none of you have to go we are the only
help there
okay so the movie itself is is quite
good I think it's Michael Bay's best
film actually it's subtle it's it's it
really works it's got a lot of momentum
and it is pathetic that the critics
decided this was only worthy of a 50%
review because it was mean to Hillary
Clinton supposedly just absurd just an
absurd again I've been railing against
the critics all this week because I
don't know whether Black Panther is good
or bad it might be good it might be
great it might be bad I have no clue
because it was 100% on Rotten Tomatoes
and half of the reviews are all about
how important the film is there's an
idiotic idiotic tweet out from salon.com
talking about how Black Panther is
important because the first blockbuster
released format featuring a black hero
front-and-center yes except for all of
the other ones right except for
Independence Day except for Blade except
for Hancock except for every Jamie Foxx
movie except for Django Unchained except
for except for a shaft except for all of
those it's the first one you can't trust
the critics I think is the is the bottom
line here there are certain movies where
you can trust them maybe on some of the
big-budget some of the big-budget kind
of superhero flicks that are not
politically charged you can trust them
but you can't trust them on drama that
has any sort of political orientation
the difference between the reception of
13 hours in black panther I think is a
good example of that although again
maybe Black Panther is the greatest
movie ever made if you look at its
reviews apparently the sucker is up with
Citizen Kane I'm planning on seeing it
this weekend's that I can actually give
you an honest appraisal the film itself
suffice it to say I have my doubts that
the movie is as good as the critics have
said it is simply because I don't think
any movie ever has been as good as the
critics say the Black Panther is okay
other things that I liked so yesterday
this is really cool there's a SpaceX
launch Elon Musk launched the the Falcon
Heavy which is a the most powerful
rocket ever sent in space by government
or private individual and then he landed
the the some of the portions of the
launch back down on the tarmac which is
super cool here's what it looked like
nine eight seven six
[Applause]
okay so pretty cool and then you can see
that the two of the two of the pods
ended up landing back down on the tarmac
right exactly where they're supposed to
go it looked it looks like a ballet it's
really cool like I don't eat that is and
just is they can reuse them again as
opposed to sort of being destroyed or
left in the ocean really really neat so
there it's designed to deliver maximum
payload to low Earth orbit of 64 tons
which is the equivalent to putting five
double-decker buses in space instead
they sent the his old cherry red Tesla
sportscar so there's a shot of the of
the Tesla sports car in space and then
there's a space suited mannequin
strapped in the driver's seat and the
radio is set to play David Bowie's
soundtrack on a loop apparently the
rocket was so powerful that it actually
blasted them outside the elliptical
orbit they're originally going for and
there's a chance that the car actually
lands on Mars which is pretty amazing so
it is essentially three of spacex
workhorse falcon nine vehicles strapped
together and as the usual practice for
spacex all three booth stages returned
to earth to attempt at controlled
landings
two of the three came down the third
booster was due to settle on a drone
ship station several hundred kilometres
out at sea but it was unable to slow its
descent by reigniting sufficient engines
and missed the target and was destroyed
as it hit the water at some 500
kilometers an hour but by then the upper
stage of the Falcon Heavy according to
BBC was heading on a trajectory that
would hopefully take it toward Mars
orbit so pretty amazing stuff a lot of
people are upset about this because they
say that the government has sponsored an
Elon Musk with something with five
hundred million dollars of subsidies I
promise you that they've spent a lot
more on that than that on NASA and now
again I'm not in favor of government
subsidies I think that Elon Musk is a
very wealthy man and I'm not sure that
the government subsidies are necessary
but you can still recognize what a cool
thing happens with government subsidies
even if you oppose the government
subsidies okay time for some things that
I hate
okay so there's a gay Olympian who's now
saying that Mike Pence vice president of
the United States who is set to lead the
Olympic delegation should not do so why
because he says that Mike Pence backed
gay conversion therapy we're going into
the Olympics and myself and Adam rip on
are the two first openly gay males
competing the Olympics and it's just
incredible to see how times have changed
because of people like you and athletes
in the past and and so many people that
have paved the way but then to have
someone leading the delegation that's
like directly attacked the LGBT
community and just like a cabinet in
general that just sort of stands against
us and has tried to do things to set us
back it just it just seems like a bad
fit okay that is a lie okay Mike Pence
never supported gay conversion therapy
which is the therapy where people are
given electroshock and essentially
tortured in an attempt to create an
association between the pain and
homosexual thoughts right Pence has
never supported that there is no
evidence that Pence has ever supported
that they've been to hit with this
accusation over and over and over it is
simply not true it doesn't matter
pence tried to reach out to this guy
this guy refused to talk to him and so
the media covered his pens tried to
reach out to gay stay Olympian after gay
Olympian accuses him of homophobia
that's not what happened here okay what
happened here is that this guy lied
about Mike Pence on national television
and the left has been lying about Mike
Pence on national television about this
stuff for quite a while what pens did
say is that any sort of bill that
includes funding for individuals who are
seeking to to have psychological therapy
should include coverage for people who
are seeking to change their own their
own sexual orientation right which could
be talk therapy right it could be
anything the bottom line is what he's
saying is that if we're gonna give money
to you for some sort of therapy you get
to choose the therapy that you want to
choose that is not the same thing at all
as saying that Mike Pence is in favor of
trying to shock gay people into not
being gay anymore that's absurd but
again lies can travel around the world
faster than the truth can put its boots
on okay other things that I hate so an
NPR music critic came out yesterday and
said that Justin Timberlake embodies a
white privilege why no one really
understands why Justin Timberlake's
entire career and art is based on his
ability to be smooth to create music
that seduces us with
references to the past with
appropriations with artful mixes and
never quite shows any struggle but we
are living in a moment of struggle and
we want our pop music to also reflect
that struggle today privilege so I'm so
bored with her it's white male privilege
for him to use pop icons of the past for
his music it's it that that's white male
privilege okay then I think that we're
going to it for the use of tonal music
we're going to have to credit every
black star with using the rise of tonal
music in the West right it's not true
the tonal music exists everywhere
equally on earth it's not true right and
they're different cultures that have
different types of music pop music goes
a lot more to the classical heritage in
terms of the the tones that it uses than
it does to example for to for example
Indian music right I mean like the
country of India or Chinese music it
owes a lot to Western music right the
idea that that cultural appropriation is
not part and parcel of culture itself is
absurd the idea that that Justin
Timberlake embodied white privilege by
singing songs that weren't protest
chants and that in order for the NFL to
really have a pop star that mattered the
NFL had to have Beyonce to a Black
Panthers routine again is just absurd
again poisoning our culture is something
the left is intent on doing and
polarizing us along every possible line
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
much much more I'm Ben Shapiro there's
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018